يصبح الناس غريبين من
حولك لأنني أشاهدك تقريبًا تفعل السحر
في البيئات الاجتماعية ويبدو الأمر كما لو
أنك تمتلك قوة
خارقة معينة السحرة هم أشخاص أقوياء
[موسيقى]
ضعوا صورتك وريموند ريموند
أنا دوغ وأي شخص آخر  تشرفت
بمقابلتك وكيف تربطكما علاقة
مثالية ، سأحصل حتى على
اتصال بينكما يا رفاق ، وسحب
هاتفك ، ونفس
الشيء اسحب هاتفك ، عملك
مثير للاهتمام حقًا لأنك
تدمج نوعًا من القديم  - سحر المدرسة
مع التكنولوجيا الجديدة حتى تعرف أن هناك
تاريخًا من السحرة كانوا في
طليعة التكنولوجيا ، أول
متسلل على الإطلاق كان ساحرًا وربما يحمل
هاتفك في يدك اليمنى ، أمسك
هاتفك بيدك اليسرى ، سأعود
خلفك مثل  هذا بيديك الأخرى
تدخل بين ساقيك في
يدك الأخرى ، أفعل لي معروفاً ، ارفع
إصبعًا واحدًا مثل هذا الشيء نفسه ، شاهده
قد يأخذ أصابعك هكذا وأنا
أتطرق إليهم جاهزًا واحدًا اثنان ثلاثة أنا  سوف
أتطرق إليهم على هذا النحو ، لا تتركهم على ما يرام
لأنك
تتلقى مكالمة وتتلقى مكالماتك ، فنحن جميعًا من بعضنا
البعض ، نعم ، أجب عليها وتأكد من
أنك متصل هل أنت متصل
نعم وإليك  شيء لا ينقطع ، لا
تغلق الهاتف ، قم بإحضار هاتفك إلى أسفل مثل
هذا لأنك لا تزال متصلاً ، انظر
أنه لا يزال متصلاً. شاهد
أصابعك على ثلاثة ، واحد اثنان ، ثلاثة ،
سأفصلهم عن بعضهم البعض جاهزًا مثل هذا
الفصل ، احصل على هذا  تاريخ من
الترقيع والبناء وطوال
الوقت منذ أن عرفت عام 1902 عن الآن ،
تقدمت التقنيات بشكل أسرع بكثير من
السحرة القادرين على مواكبة التطورات التي
أتصورها كساحر في العصر الحديث ، يجب أن
يكون من الصعب الاحتفاظ بالأسرار والحفاظ على
ما تفعله تقنية سرية  كان
سيئًا للسحر وجيدًا للسحر ولكن
في نفس الوقت لأن السحرة اعتادوا
على حماية أسرارهم جيدًا وفي
الوقت الحاضر يمكنك الذهاب إلى YouTube عندما
تجد الكثير من الأسرار السحرية عندما
يكون الأمر يشبه
تنزيل 595  إنه سر بسيط أنك
لا تحترمه بنفس الاحترام كما هو الحال
عندما استغرقت سنوات للتعلم أو
التعقب أو الاكتشاف